bueno el balance ha sido de una votación
totalmente
masiva antes les contaba que la
participación sin tener números sobre la
mesa porque esto lo tiene que dar el
comité electoral a simple vista ya
parecía totalmente masiva de hecho ambos
candidatos han votado entre gran
expectación en las primeras horas de la
mañana muchísima gente también ha
acudido a las urnas en las primeras
horas de la mañana por lo que se puede
prever que en esto en estas últimas dos
horas los colegios han estado muchísimo
más vacíos que que en las primeras horas
hemos visto Aunque mal Philips
que entre vítores de muchísima gente que
lo esperaba Para verle cómo votaba decía
él a los medios que la primavera estaba
a punto de llegar aquí al país San
Antonio en alusión a un posible cambio
en el gobierno en caso de que el entre y
gane estas elecciones en cuanto a ha
llamado a que el proceso democrático se
produzca con la mayor calma posible que
no haya problemas y de hecho podemos
constatar que no ha habido grandes
problemas ni grandes incidencias también
hemos podido hablar con alguno de los
interventores en estas mesas electorales
y nos comentaba que él en su caso nunca
había visto una participación tan alta
la participación alta entonces puede ser
una de las sorpresas de este día y ya
veremos Quién es elegido como el
presidente al respecto veíamos en las
imágenes que ya están contando estos
votos cuando se esperan los resultados
Albert
los resultados ahora mismo Aquí son las
5 de la tarde se espera que entre las 7
y las 8 de la tarde en un par o tres de
horas ya se empiecen a saber algunos de
los resultados recordemos que aquí el
proceso de contabilización se hace en
cada colegio electoral
esto se envían el recuento de votos al
comité electoral el isk y es el isk el
encargado de después compartir estos
resultados con los medios de
comunicación y de forma abierta Por lo
tanto en unas dos o tres horas ya
podemos empezar a ver
cómo va el proceso electoral y cuáles
son los votos Eso sí se espera que hasta
el final de todo no se sepa realmente
Cuál es el candidato que va a ganar
estas elecciones o que va los dos que
van a pasar a segunda ronda debido a que
será una una puja muy muy a la par al
final el país está totalmente polarizado
por lo que se espera que hasta los
últimos momentos no se sepa un resultado
Real